[Musique]
eric woerth député de l'oise président
ait l'air de la commission des finances
de l'assemblée nationale est l'invité
d'auditions publiques bonsoir bonsoir et
merci beaucoup d'avoir accepté notre
invitation l'invitation des chaînes
parlementaires du figaro et de la fp je
précise tout de suite pour les
internautes qui nous suivent sur le site
du figaro bien sûr comme chaque semaine
vous pouvez réagir sur le chat et puis
je me ferais le relais de vos
observations et même de vos questions
tout à l'heure pour eric woerth avec moi
sur ce plateau
jim jarrassé et polo bria messieurs
bonsoir
dans un instant deux parlementaires eric
woerth seront là pour vous interpeller
le sénateur socialiste martial bourquin
et la députée de la république en marche
amélie de montchanin et puis orial
mancini et ludovic faux seront là pour
la dernière partie de l'émission nous
parlerons notamment de l'enjeu des
européennes avec déjà les indiscrétions
bien sûr sur le texte que va publier
dans les heures qui viennent le chef de
l'état et puis on vous interrogera bien
sûr sur la campagne de votre parti mené
par françois-xavier bellamy sur lequel
vous aviez quand même émis des réserves
vous verrez on verra tout à l'heure si
vous exprimez votre fidélité totale et
entière à votre parti eric woerth bien
sûr la crise sociale avec les gilets
jaunes il ya de moins en moins parc
participants le samedi lui accorder
heures dans certaines villes alors que
se poursuit le grand débat est ce que
vous êtes confiant dans son issue
je sais plus très bien ce que ça veut
dire une issue à cette crise tous les
samedis évidemment de moins en moins de
personnes enfin ça fait toujours
beaucoup de gens dans les rues avec plus
ou moins de violence selon les samedis
c'est évidemment insupportable je pense
que tout le monde aujourd'hui le
le dénonce enfin toute personne
raisonnable pays était menée elle
dénoncé parce que c'est le début autant
le début c'était une colère qu'on
pouvait comprendre beaucoup des sujets
les avions en avion porter un certain
nombre et nous avions indiqué au
président de la république il pouvait y
avoir des difficultés absolument majeur
sur les taxes carburant etc autant
maintenant ça n'a plus aucun sens
dénoncé même pas vraiment ce que les
personnes qui aujourd'hui vont
manifester ce qu'elle souhaite ce
qu'elles veulent
la problème d'autorité de l'état qui ne
parvient pas justement à refermer
oui moi je vivrai je pense qu'une
obligation de résultat de l'état sur un
jardin de vos solutions mais moi je suis
pas un spécialiste de la maintien de
l'ordre et de la et de la police c'est à
l'état de définir les moyens en tout cas
un état là cinq ou sixième puissance
mondiale elle doit avoir les moyens à un
moment donné de dire stop à les
manifestants ne font pas leur boulot
je n'ai pas de forces de l'ordre devant
les policiers les gens de la vision la
gcm et font tout ce qu'il peut mon dieu
ceux qui sont au front au contrat il
mérite
il perd est neutre notre salut quotidien
et nos bravo enfin il ya un moment donné
où il ya un problème de moyens où il ya
un problème de réglementation ou il ya
un problème de législation où il ya un
problème de justice l'ont fait il ya un
problème il ya un problème qui fait
qu'en france chaque semaine on peut
manifester de manifeste de ne me dérange
pas c'est la constitution c'est même
quelque chose qui est fondamentalement
inscrit dans notre dans notre raison
d'être démocratique mais que ça se
transforme de cette façon là c'est
inacceptable et totalement inacceptable
faut interdire de manière ciblée sera
moi je pense qu'à un moment donné il
faut il faut aller très loin et très
fort oui à un moment donné il faut dire
stop
il n'y a pas de raison que ça lui dit
prochain il y ait des nouvelles on fait
quoi alter dire des manifestations lors
ce que c'est possible trouver tous les
moyens pour le faire
et puis si la justice veut casser cela
le 4 1 mais le gouvernement doit tous
utiliser des cortèges qui ne sont pas
autorisés il ya des manifestations dans
certains pays
les références de leurs péchés il faut
je veux vous pouvez laisser la
circulation se faire peut-être vous
pouvez rami les manières de ne pas
transformer des vies dans des champs de
bataille et ça doit être fait en tout
cas l'état il a une obligation de
résultat sur sur ce plan là on peut pas
contempler au pire sens du terme comme
un observateur ce qui se passe de samedi
en samedi
et puis sans arrêt pleurnicher le samedi
soir pour dire mon dieu il y avait
encore des casseurs dans la rue qu'est
ce que c'est que ça c'est pas possible
et puis la démocratie non il faut
aujourd'hui agir pour que ça n'existe
plus c'est le discours que tient le chef
de l'état il a eu des mots assez durs
pour ceux qui comme vous ont menti s'en
moquent de ces mots durs si les chefs de
l'état
jeudi les chefs de l'état il n'est pas
patron de l'opposition ou quidam banal
il est le chef de l'état il a tous les
moyens aujourd'hui pour stopper cela
donc il doit le stopper c'est son
obligation sur le grand débat quelle
sortie aussi multiples sorties fiscales
notamment est ce qu'il faut comme
certains proposent une tranche
supplémentaire sur les hauts revenus par
exemple est ce qu ils font un retour de
la taxe carbone que vous qui êtes le
spécialiste de ces questions chez les
républicains
qu'est ce que vous dites mais moi je dis
que ce grand débat d'abord il ya un peu
une
un peu de d'indigestion de débats qu'il
ya des débats maintenant partout dans
tous les sens
il ya des ballons d'essai vous venez
d'en citer un certain nombre
d'enseignements et des baudruches fiscal
et que vous lancez un truc ça éclate
tout de suite c'est la liste est
d'ailleurs assez impressionnante
les droits de succession la taxe
d'habitation pour les 20% des personnes
les plus aisées comme on dit l'impôt sur
le revenu au premier euro
la peau sur le revenu des catégories les
plus aisées aussi je fais ça les niches
fiscales pour les emplois familiaux et
ses idées malgré tout dans tout ce que
vous venez d'énumérer non enfin jeu même
en cherchant bien tout si cette boîte à
outils on la connaît par coeur pour tout
vous dire il entend les terroirs de
bercy de l'entente il ya qu un seul truc
qui ne fait absolument pas le plein
débat c'est la réduction des dépenses
publiques
et je ne dis pas que le chef de l'état
d'ailleurs n'a pas souhaité le faire
il a cherché dans sa lettre sa première
lettre pour dire va y avoir un grand
débat vous verrez c'est formidable il
avait écrit des questions et dans ces
questions
il y avait quelques questions sur la
dépense lui donc un débat c'est d'abord
l'exercice d'une responsabilité et la
responsabilité
lorsqu'on est à la tête de l'état c'est
de poser les questions fiscales mais
d'abord de poser les questions des
dépenses parce qu'a priori par la
fiscalité bien sûr apporter des recettes
au fonctionnement et l'évasion fiscale
que certains évoquent les ministres
effectivement on entend beaucoup dire
qu'il ya une injustice fiscale dans ce
dans ce pays est ce que vous contestez
cette idée là alors oui je tendance un
peu a contesté cette cette idée là parce
qu'elle est trop simple et trop
simpliste et que je trouve qu'on a une
dérive de simplisme et que cette dérive
de simplisme elle peut rendre très
compliqué après l'exercice de la
démocratie l'exercice du pouvoir la
compréhension mutuelle des uns et des
autres oui nous avons beaucoup de
fiscalité il ya des prélèvements qui
sont en dehors
des normes de toutes les normes
internationales donc nous avons beaucoup
beaucoup de fiscalité pourquoi parce que
nous avons beaucoup beaucoup de dépense
publique donc beaucoup beaucoup de
service public même si les français ne
le voit plus ou ne l'entendent plus au
fond ne le comprennent plus quand
lorsque on entend dans ces débats ou
alors ce qu'on lit dans toutes les pages
des journaux à mais il faudrait nous on
veut bien payer de l'impôt mais on veut
savoir où ça va mais on sait où ça va
heureusement d'ailleurs
on sait exactement où ça va ça
rembourser une grande partie de la dette
accumulée
ça permet d'avoir une école gratuite ça
permet d'avoir une santé de bonne
qualité très bonne qualité gratuite ça
permet d'avoir des allocations
familiales des prestations sociales
on est bien aussi le seul impôt on sait
où ça va oui le lapin pris c'est le prix
du service public
et encore le sert et aux cornes sommes
en déficit donc c'est le prix du service
public et encore ce prix minoré parce
que derrière il ya des générations
futures qui paieront ce que nous n'avons
pas payé nous mêmes donc la question
n'est pas tellement de savoir s'il faut
mieux répartir l'impôt si on peut le
faire si peut être plus juste plus
équilibrée
chacun doit payer en fonction de ses
moyens évidemment mais la vraie question
est de savoir ce que nous pas ce que
nous payons
mais la question est de savoir le volume
de la dépense publique ce volume de la
dépense publique aujourd'hui il est
totalement décalée mais sa hâte
extrêmement vaste univers de toujours
plus de services publics c'est ce qu'ils
disent et j'ai je n'aurais pu le départ
oui comment on fait pour résoudre cette
équation mais si vous posez la question
en même temps est-ce que tu es d'accord
pour qu'ils aient plus de services
publics sur telle chose est ce que tu es
d'accord pour financer les services
publics par une augmentation d'impôts et
vous répondre il vous répondra non donc
évidemment une irresponsabilité le
suggère que l'on il ya plein d'endroits
un peu partout à paris a dit talisman
non mais un peu partout il ya 20 30 40
50 milliards d'euros on dépense plus que
les allemands auteur de je sais pas 150
200 milliards d'euros
donc on voit bien sur des scènes
absolument gigantesque nous avons un
besoin de toujours un besoin d'états et
la france sera toujours un pays dans
lesquels on dépensera plus parce que
notre culture c'est celle ci on doit
avoir un accès à l'école on doit avoir
un accès aux meilleurs services mais en
échange de tout cela il faut des règles
il faut probablement aussi mieux
verrouillés certain nombre de droits
affecté un certain nombre de devoirs des
devoirs je le premier ministre a évoqué
cela on évoque depuis bien longtemps et
contre l'avis du parti
vous êtes avec nicolas sarkozy on avait
évoqué à plusieurs reprises sacré sans
arrêt des débats qui sont ces pistes
qu'on avait nous même mis en place pour
l'avoir plupart des cas donc je veux
dire malheureusement la france elle a
plutôt tendance à faire de la marche
arrière que va faire de la marche avant
et c'est une inquiétude et même quelque
chose qui rend triste un responsable
public la france n'avance pas elle ne
réforme pas l'état comme elles devraient
le faire elle ne déclenche pas les
débats en responsabilité que nous
devrions avait estimé que l'accès des
gilets jaunes justement va marquer un
nouvel arrêt à ce que vous appelez donc
sa chance
est ce que vous estimez par exemple que
on a renoncé à la baisse des dépenses
publiques est ce qu'on à renoncer aux
économies que vous appelez de vos voeux
en tout cas le président laplink quand
il a été lui il voulait révolutionner la
france il a transformé en révolte
populaire s'était pas tout à fait ce qui
était ce qui était prévu et donc il rend
la réforme plus difficile puisque la
capacité d'acceptabilité de la réforme
est difficile et c'est très difficile de
déclencher un débat populaire jeu
absolument pour tous les débats et c'est
en réalité à débat contrat c'est parce
qu'il avait pas de débat que tout d'un
coup il ya presque un excès de débats
cet excès de débat on veut le retrouve
pas dans la décision la france elle a
besoin de beaucoup de décisions
et d'en débattre mais aussi de beaucoup
décidé aujourd'hui une indigestion de
débats meilleur en termes de décisions
c'est relativement indigents il ya huit
mois tendent encore qu'un tout petit
problème il ne fait pas attendre vous
croyez que le monde il nous est en vous
croyez vous qu avec nos parts de marché
françaises qui font notre pouvoir
d'achat qui est le pouvoir d'achat des
français
vous croyez qu'on a le temps d'attendre
vous croyez qu'on est élu à la une
responsabilité suprême à la tête de
l'état français pour uniquement
déclenché un débat pour faire faire
parler français votre feuille de route
sur les deux ans qui viennent
ça je ne le crois pas du tout donc je ne
sais pas comment on va atterrir jeunes
en armes il est tout ce que je sais
c'est que sur la fraude fiscale puisque
vous l'évoquez la fraude fiscale c'est
ce dont on parle toujours quand on n'a
pas d'idée c'est à dire que vous
regardez fait des programmes vous dites
mais nous mêmes on l'a fait d'ailleurs à
certains moments pour garder ou dit wap
j'arrive pas à financer telle ou telle
mesure supplémentaire alors je dis allez
on va on va faire 10 20 30 elles auront
kombouaré sait pas qu on ne sait pas oui
c'est une estimation précise par exemple
de ce que l'état pourrait gagner on
n'est pas du tout en éradiquant ces
sites ont fait que cette personne la fin
du chiffre entre 5 et 80 milliards mais
ces chiffres d'abord voyez que ça ne
veut rien dire et que vous n'aurez aucun
ministre sérieux je parle de gens
sérieux qui vous diront combien et la
fraude fiscales vu que c'est cacher et
que donc c était c'est difficile à
évaluer
lorsque je suis devenu ministre du
budget il ya maintenant dix ans j'ai
créé une délégation nationale de lutte
contre la fraude
cette délégation nationale de lutte
contre la fraude avec pour vocation de
réunir justement fraude fiscale fraude
sociale les impôts les services sociaux
l'urssaf etc et de d'essayer de faire en
sorte d'avoir une vision globale et la
première chose que j'ai demandée à cette
délégation
c'était une évaluation du montant de la
fraude ils n'ont jamais été capables de
le faire et j'aime et je vois que 10 ans
après c'est toujours le cas il n'y a pas
de méthode il ya une incapacité à faire
alors il faut lutter resort
non ils mentent pas ils savent pas il
donne le chiffre qui les arrange
comme ils n'ont pas de répondre sans
réelle en général à la question qui est
posée parce qu'en général on propose une
dépense en france un politique il
propose souvent une dépendance
il propose une dépense supplémentaire il
faudrait faire ça en plus a coûté plus
cher et quand on vous
quand on demandait comment vous le
financeur général du var va évidemment
regardé il n'y aurait pas de déficit
public
6 s'il n'y avait pas de fraude fiscale
est d'ailleurs souvent ces mêmes
chiffres
c'est souvent parfois les mêmes si elles
décident public d'une centaine de
milliards ou 2 81 milliards à la fraude
fiscale 7,80 voyez on doit pas se serrer
la ceinture
on doit pas tenter de réformer notre
état pour essayer de le rendre plus
durables non pas la planète cette fois
ci mais notre société française forme
prenantes par exemple l'exemple de
l'assurance chômage
il ya eu des annonces qui ont été faites
la semaine dernière par edouard philippe
est ce que vous pensez que ça va
suffisamment loin en tout cas dans ce
qui a été déjà un peu annoncé est ce que
vous pensez que ça va dans la bonne
direction suffisamment vite enfin moi je
remarque que sur la méthode c'était un
échec total il y avait la volonté
d'essayer de sortir par le dialogue
social c'est un dialogue qui doit
aboutir à des résultats c'est pas un
débat c'est un vrai dialogue pour
décider on s'aperçoit que c'était
impossible de le mener on verra ce que
l'état dira on verra ce que la ministre
du travail ce que est ce que ça libérera
finalement les capacités de l'état
réforme est vraiment en tout cas je
pense que le dialogue social c'est
difficile en tout cas le dialogue entre
syndicats et patronat se compliquer pour
passer des étapes pour gérer les choses
pourquoi pas mais pour passer des étapes
de rupture c'est compliqué on verra sur
l'état est capable de le faire mais il
ya des questions d'indemnisation
aujourd'hui du chômage il ya cette
question elle est clairement posée en
plus limité les
et poser dans les infos sur en niveau
mais il faut pas y'a pas de raison de
tomber sur les cadres on a besoin des
cadres en france mais il ya peut-être
des délais ya peut-être une dégressivité
tout ça a déjà été tentée die accord
dans le passé là aussi pour gagner un
peu les réformes vous allez dire que nos
jours sur leur droite des républicains
je rejoins le programme délicat qui a
été suffisamment travaillé la primaire
des républicains qui n'est pas au siècle
dernier qui était alors qu'il n'ya pas
si longtemps que cela permet à résider
là elle s'applique dans plein d'autres
pays leur retraite retraite précisément
aujourd'hui ce qu'il faut réformer les
retraites c'est comment c'est dans ce
contexte social dans lequel nous sommes
est ce que on peut encore des ambitions
est-ce que là est ce que la voie
empruntée la bonne sachant
qu'aujourd'hui on apprend par exemple
que les régimes spéciaux pourraient être
préservés
moi je peux pas commenter un truc qui
n'existe pas la carotte réforma n'existe
pas ça fait deux ans ou un an quasiment
bientôt deux ans qu'on en parle on
n'aura jamais mis autant de temps pour
faire une réforme des retraites
c'est sous la droite on a fait trois ans
je voulais public un vrai ce combat on
va toujours vous dire mais vous
critiquez mais vous n'avez pas fait on
veut toutes façons plus de rentrées
jamais passé juste une plongée d'un
mariage se dissout par exemple hoyé
vraiment ce que vous dites là vous
croyez pas ce que vous dites mais pour
écouter on est les seuls à avoir fait
moi j'ai mis je ne m'en vante pas c'est
pas un plaisir j'ai eu à faire des
millions de gens dans la rue ni millions
de gens dans la rue sur des alors ne me
dites pas que on n'a rien fait sur les
retraites on augmenter l'âge on à
réformer les régimes spéciaux au pardon
sa bière est formel puisque je suis le
même nombre de trimestres est d'ailleurs
vous ayez bien certain nombre de régimes
spéciaux aujourd'hui dont l'âge moyen de
départ est plus important regarder la
sncf ou ailleurs bon on n'a pas été
jusqu'au bout
la question de la jeunesse on n'est sans
doute pas aller jusqu'au bout des choses
là je vous regarde et vous faites 10 en
arrière mettez votre rétroviseur vous
lisez ce que ce qu'ils écrivent lfp ou
les où les journaux et vous vous le
figaro vous verrez les débats qui on est
allé jusqu'au bout des choses à ce
moment-là et croyez moi regarder les
détails c'est d'une violence extrême en
160 ans bon faut aller plus loin et les
français ils ont droit de savoir ce qui
va se passer pour leurs retraites c'est
un droit humain c'est la retraite c'est
la vie pas la mort - vermand mercenaires
se dessine
oui mais ça c'est
repoussé vous le savez bien là je vais
dans la république a dit que non ah oui
mais dans les fait vous savez bien la
dimension complète il faudra travailler
un peu plus longtemps
moi je suis favorable à ce qu'on
repousse l'âge de la retraite de façon
non politique et non polémiques
il est naturel que à partir du moment où
on vit plus longtemps même si
l'espérance de vie tu sais quoi mais il
faut il faut je crois avec l'outil peut
donner
65 ans anciennement il faut donner 65
oui il faut que le temps que vous passez
à la retraite et le temps que vous avez
passé au travail soient suffisamment
équilibré pour que les générations qui
travaillent puissent vous payez votre
retraite vous pouvez pas demander à vos
enfants de payer ce qu'ils ne peuvent
pas ils peuvent pas là pour payer vos
dettes
votre retraite et tout cela donc il faut
là dessus continue à travailler les
points c'était dans la réforme de 2010
d'ailleurs des points c'est pas un
problème c'est des modalités de calcul
c'est plus simple et plus transférable
mais c'est pas des grandes réformes
les vraies grandes réformes c'est que
les français est à peu près un régime de
retraite qui soit compatible dans
lesquelles il très peu de français qui
accèdent à des régimes dits spéciaux
aujourd'hui il ya trop de français
il n'y a pas de raison particulière pour
que ça continue parce que c'est
extraordinairement injustes par rapport
à tout ce qui vient car on retient votre
muse mesures d'âge vous c'est 65 sans
doute cela s'il n'y a pas un âge ya
quelque chose entre espérance de vie
mais regardez alors d'autres pays
regardez un peu ce que j'ai vécu de
retraite sont équilibrés grâce à la
réforme de 2010 a donc mais ça ne durera
pas parce que ça peut pas durer parce
que je pense qu'une réforme des
retraites
elle doit être aujourd'hui quasiment
automatique c'est doit plus être un
sujet les discussions politiques ou
polémique peut être un sujet gérer
uniquement en fonction de la durée de
l'âge est probablement assez vive les
années pas la pénibilité à la manière
socialiste qui était à une sorte de
l'usiné gas terrible la pénibilité
ressenti réellement au travail à un
moment donné est justifiée par la
médecine du travail paul dernière
question est-ce que vous soutenez la
taxe que bono le maire que dans ce
mercredi
sur la fin est ce que ça vous semble le
bon outil pour hanter les républicains
ont déposé un amendement qui ressemble à
ça il ya deux ans à peu près au moins
c'est prouvable c'est facile il suffit
de se référer aux débats parlementaires
est ce que c'est d'être efficace à ce
moment là on nous avait dit d'ailleurs
bono le maire en premier nous avait dit
c'est l'europe qui s'occupe de tout cela
la france va bientôt avoir ils ont tout
le monde aura raison et c'est beaucoup
trop tôt vos propositions sont beaucoup
trop beaucoup trop tôt et vous verrez ce
qui vous verrez en fait on n'a rien vu
du tout l'europe ne va rien voter du
tout et donc ce sera à la france de
montrer le chômage je pense qu'il ya un
chemin qui est celle évidemment d'une
taxation vendre la terre assez brutal
mais elle doit l'être
c'est trop faible selon vous c'est ce
qui est envisagé je pense que c'est un
peu faible
je pense à la fm comme il ya des
entreprises qui nous ressemble pas aux
gaffes a qui sont probablement dans le
champ du radar je comprends qu'on puisse
minimiser les choses mais c'est pas une
solution définitive
la solution définitive elle passe par
les discussions qui ont lieu l ocde sur
des choses plus sophistiqués dans lequel
on réfléchisse mieux' qu'un
établissement stable sur le plan sur le
plan fiscal et sur lequel on arrive à
recomposer ce que gagnent ces
entreprises et ce qu'on leur fait gagner
nous en utilisant sans arrêt c'est ces
technologies nous donner nos données par
exemple et que et que à ce moment là en
tout cas il peut pas y avoir de
différences fiscales entre une
entreprise de cette nature les autres
entreprises
merci messieurs deuxième partie
d'auditions publiques
les deux parlementaires dont je vous
annonçais l'avenue ils sont là il entre
sur le plateau
bonsoir vercieu burqa vous étiez un
auteur socialiste du doubs bonsoir à
mézidon manchin vous êtes député la
république hors marché de l'essonne une
question d'un internaute qui nous suit
sur le site du figaro c'est john il
estime que la seule solution pour
emmanuel macron aujourd'hui d'aller
jusqu'au bout de son quinquennat de le
sauver écrit-il
c'est d'acheter la paix sociale et ils
vous demandent est ce que vous êtes
d'accord
non pas du tout non acheter acheter la
paix sociale on entend ça depuis 20 ans
elle a beaucoup acheté quand même la
paix sociale ça coûtait très cher
non non pas du tout il faut je pense
qu'il faut avoir un débat responsable
avec les et les français via des
missions habituelles dernière sur
mathieu est un tournant social
oui c'est plutôt un tour 10 politique ou
un tournis ceci est assez revue le
nombre de deux
vu le nombre de propositions annoncées
le matin est contredite l'après midi je
sais moi ça me donne plutôt le tournis
que le tournant avec leurs amis les de
montchanin je vous en prie bonsoir la
première interpellé eric woerth
ça peut lui c'est violent cola n'ont pas
forcément vous allez voir comment c'est
entrer dans la même commission à
l'assemblée on s'interpelle souvent moi
je voulais revenir sur deux sujets qui
ont fait débat et qui ont été d'ailleurs
évoqué dans votre interview juste avant
sur les contreparties
j'ai été assez choqué de voir que
laurent wauquiez expliqué qu'il fallait
des contreparties de nature de travaux
d'intérêt général et au fond ça remet
dans la machine l'idée qu'il y aurait ce
pseudo assistanat et or face duquel il
faudrait avoir une démarche assez
punitive
j'appelle que travaux d'intérêt général
c'est comme très chargé c'est en lien au
code pénal
moi j'ai quand même l'impression dans
tout le débat qui a un gros sujet pour
le coup prioritaires et qui peut être un
tournant social qui luttent contre le
non recours donner priorité à
l'accompagnement il devrait insertion et
dont je voudrais comprendre un peu sur
ce sujet là comment la droite peut avoir
justement un virage pour arriver à
passer non pas des grands débats des
grands concepts mais vraiment à la
réalité de terrain
est ce que le système social qui coûte
effectivement aux contribuables soit
vraiment plus efficace et amène les
personnes à sortir vraiment la pauvreté
je pense qu'il faut une contrepartie il
faut des ou des contreparties
je pense que quand on a le rsa bien
mal à vivre avec lui récemment on est à
un des pays où ça existe et c'est tant
mieux
heureusement pour les français pour la
france il me semble assez naturel qu'en
face de cela au bout d'un certain temps
dans certaines conditions
tout ça doit être discutée mais qui est
une contrepartie d'intérêt général qui
quelques heures donner à la collectivité
allait s'occuper de la bibliothèque
s'occuper de ci ou de ça donnait
quelques heures à la collectivité parce
que la collectivité vous donne vous
donne à ce moment là un filet de
sécurité qui n'existe pas dans d'autres
d'autres pays qu'à côté qu'à côté il est
aussi une forme d'obligation de
formation de toutes natures qui permette
de sortir de cet état de pauvreté qui ne
peut être que on peut l'espérer en tout
cas passagers ou ponctuels et on ne peut
jamais faire en sorte que l'enfant
personne ne peut vouloir qu'on est à
pauvreté sur les durable et que la
personne si en piste pendant des années
et des années
donc il faut la sortir de tout cela et à
un moment donné il faut aussi mettre un
peu d'autorité et je pense que notamment
sur la formation il ya beaucoup beaucoup
à faire surtout dans des périodes où ce
seront nous sommes dans des périodes qui
ne sont des périodes où il ya encore un
chômage de masse et pourtant il ya de la
croissance
et pourtant il ya dix ans il cherche qui
cherchent tout le monde le sait charges
du ménage de peut-être plutôt donné aux
amoureux du priorité justement à
l'insertion à l'activité à la formation
qui permet de trouver un emploi plutôt
qu'à des travaux d'intérêt je suis au
travail de ce que je pense qu'il faut
aussi natation très punitive est très
judicieux ministre japonais des
contreparties de la part des droits et
des devoirs l'idée que l'état avait le
devoir d'accompagner et que la personne
avait ensuite le devoir de participer
pour justement pouvoir dans une
dynamique d'emploi ce qui est assez
différent de la démarche premier
ministre a pas tout à fait préciser ce
qu'il entendait par là ici c'est fait il
s'est fait totalement
on a des contreparties effectivement le
contexte la réponse et c'est assez
fournie et c'est ce que tu fais la
majorité et qui est une démarche qui
n'est pas là vous n'êtes pas tout à fait
sur la même longueur d'ondés
contrepartie enfin je ne peux pas rester
là on peut passer pour caler derrière
moi j'ai une question sur adp aéroports
de paris on s'apprête le gouvernement
s'apprête à privatiser aéroports de
paris qui représente une belle
entreprise qui crée même des entreprises
à travers le monde et qui fonctionne
bien est ce que le sénat a pris position
à plus plus de 246 votants contre cette
privatisation que gauche-droite
réunissent gauche dont les communistes
socialistes républicains centristes en
disant pourquoi faire une erreur
pareille il y adeux spectre des
autoroutes et on s'apprête
vraisemblablement à faire peut-être pire
avec adp et donc quelle est votre
position sur ce dossier
je pense que il nous reste quelques mois
pour faire en sorte que le maximum de
parlementaires maximum de mer le maximum
de présidents de conseils généraux mais
aussi responsables syndicaux
d'associations puissent se faire
entendre en sang pour dire au président
de la république abandonner ce projet
abandonné ce projet parce que c'est une
erreur une erreur économique bat parce
que erreur économique que 174 millions
d'euros versés à l'état cette année
c'est quand même pas rien mais surtout
avec l'évolution du trafic aérien
on sait très bien que cette manne
financière va encore augmenter
moi je suis
je bosse pas mal de questions sur
l'opportunité ou la nécessité de
privatiser monde il enfin cette
privatisation pendant 70 ans de la
gestion d'aéroports de paris comme
d'ailleurs de la française des jeux pour
tout vous dire sur est jugée moins de
moins de moins de doute je suis pas par
nature contre les privatisations et les
sons nouveaux contre les privatisations
je pense qu'on y est on a des
participations trop élevés dans pas mal
d'entreprises et qu'on aurait le même
contrôle avec des prélats des
participations au moins élevé mais en
l'occurrence il ya beaucoup d'aéroports
qui sont pas privatiser qui sont gérées
par la puissance publique c'est une
frontière donc c'est aussi important la
sécurité bien sûr resterait du niveau de
l'état régalien à la paf la douane mais
mais mais mais c'est plus que ça la
sécurité je pense et puis surtout les
conditions financières ne sont pas
claires je trouve que les hypocrites n
est pas clair enfin le vent qu'on puisse
dire c'est tout c est quand même
relativement floues on ne sait pas
l'état veut tirer à peu près 15
milliards d'euros si j'ai bien compris
10 ou 15 milliards d'euros
dad ep bon c'est déjà c'est beaucoup
d'argent c'est déjà beaucoup d'argent
donc il doit vendre une part très
significative des 50 ou 51% qu'il qu'il
possédait alors vous avez dit que vous
êtes hésitant pour l'instant moi je
pense que c'est pas une bonne idée et
que
je pense que le seul à voter a voté
contre et le sénateur a raison c'est à
dire que les dividendes aujourd'hui
versées par adp alors peut-être ne
sont-ils pas éternel mais enfin les
dividendes versés aujourd'hui sont
largement suffisants pour abonder si la
milice devait absolument abonder un
fonds supplémentaire des doses
entreprise très bien mais d'abord
défoncé existe déjà pour tout vous dire
on de transport qu on en crée un nouveau
et puis ce les si vous mettez française
des jeux et à des pnj vous tombez sur
des sommes d'hésitante qui sont au moins
au moins de même niveau de joie de
nantes pourquoi pourquoi tout cela est
ce que c'est pour mieux gérer adp est ce
qu'on se dit au fond adp serez mieux
gérer de bientôt est une entreprise
elle a pris ce française une entreprise
chinoise une entreprise je ne sais pas
quoi
tous les beaucoup de gens vont me voyant
les nations
peut-être peut-être que ce serait il le
devrait mais ça ne veut pas dire que
l'état 800 millions d'euros l'année
dernière
alors peut-être doit pas y avoir un
consensus à 3 autour de cette table
madame bas il n'y aura pas consensus
parce que c'est son gouvernement qui
veut l'utiliser en termes généraux ce
qui est sûr c'est que la réflexion qu'on
a c'est l'état pour pouvoir quand même
réallouer ses investissements en
fonction des priorités et que si à un
moment donné il fallait que l'état
investit soutiennent et permettent aux
aéroports de grandir je fais lui une
circonscription où il ya les pistes
d'orly
donc je suis très concerné pour moi et
bien sûr les enjeux de sécurité
effectivement les choses seront garantis
pour moi ya aussi le sujet des riverains
et il faut que l'état est un rôle de
régulation très fort et là c'est le rôle
de plein de l'état que l'état abandonné
puis se dire je sors l'activité qui
avait besoin d'un soutien pour les
soutenir de l'innovation de rupture et
finalement l'économie de demain
je pense que c'est une démarche qu'on
comprend ensuite effectivement tout
l'enjeu c'est que l'état ne brade pas
l'actif et que puissant retirer mais
cela mais savez vous avez un monopole de
fait plus 80 % du fret aérien passe pas
et reports de paris a river et dans le
préambule de la régulation dit on dit
bien que tous nos vols
j'ai aucun problème idéologique
je trouve ça je trouve que ça n'a pas
beaucoup d'intérêt parce que la
réallocation moyens non alloué les
dividendes au financement du fonds les
puits vous dites que les dividendes de
la française des jeux
da dp éventuellement les sur dividende
et dividende
zheng jie restants sont affectés à la
création de ce fonds mais ça fait
beaucoup de fonds aussi mes lignes
challe à vous avez la bpi qui intervient
vous avez lé grand emprunt qui ont pris
plusieurs formes
lancé par nicolas sarkozy à quelques
quelques années bon tout ça fait
beaucoup d'argent au fond on se demande
pourquoi on a besoin d'un troisième
fonds auxquels on va plus rien je
travaille à la demande du premier
ministre avec d'autres députés en ce
moment sur la loi de programmation la
recherche et le lien entre la recherche
publique et la recherche privée pour
justement être une économie innovante
donc nous allons pouvoir en détail
regardez d'ailleurs l'articulation de
ces fonds et soutien réel ou fictif mise
en relation et pouvant se faisant des
trucs pareils
pourquoi on les regarde il assiste et
une dispersion moyens c'est pas une
réallocation c'est une dispersion de 2,2
de moyens jeu honnêtement je pense je ne
vaux pas ce combat sinon peut-être
faut-il resserré mieux la gestion des
paies diraient les investissements à
venir qui peuvent être financés opinion
ça fait très bien le lien c'est le mot
vous avez prononcé d'investissement fait
très bien avec la question que j'avais
suivante qui concerne l'europe
votre candidat aux européennes avec
bellamy a dit une phrase sur lequel j'ai
été assez surprise puisqu'il dit
l'europe que je veux incarner crois que
le plus important n'est pas de
transformer mais de transmettre et là
j'ai un sujet c'est que je pense que
l'état la puissance publique et l'europe
ne peut pas se dire qu'aujourd'hui elle
est arrivée à un point où elle n'a plus
à se transformer plus à se réformer et
qu'il ne faudrait juste qu'elles
transmettent une situation aujourd'hui
qui quand même inégalitaire inefficace
et qu'on a effectivement devant nous un
énorme combat d'innovation'
compétitivité à mener moi je pense que
en tant personnellement je me sens très
progressiste et je ne comprends pas
pourquoi votre famille politique est à
ce point
finalement dans un compteur d'un
conservatisme qui va bientôt être
bientôt du déclinisme parce que
politique
faby politique elle a à peu près sa
cohérence vous inquiétez pas nous devons
évident pour reprendre la formule nous
devons transmettre des des politiques ou
des situations réforme est transformé
chargé des relations amène évidemment
son sont enfin on va peut-être ce qu'il
faudra éviter c'est de transmettre tous
les samedis un mouvement d'une et jaune
donc ça ça me semblerait ce qui
semblerait mieux donc essayons de
réformer sérieusement il solidement
notre pays et je note que la réforme de
l'état par exemple qui est essentiel
c'est sur l'europe en disant qu'il y
avait surtout pas réformé qui fait
transmettre j'aimerais savoir quelle
europe ils voteront ce que j'ai pas vu
ses déclarations moi je n'imagine pas un
instant qu'une tête de liste les
républicains ne soit pas réformateur
dont qu'il est un réformateur également
comme comme moi même et comme nous le
sommes tous dans cette droite
progressiste mais le progressé de de
transmettre dans de bonnes conditions
des politiques publiques
je parle aussi bien de la dette grèce
estime être progressiste vous le prenez
aussi à votre vie est très disputé ce ce
qualificatif vous le prenez un pêcheur
pas les gemmes le progrès comme tous les
français mais j'ai français il est il
aime pas le recul il préfère le problème
est qu'il faut conserver un peu plus
conservateur et l'assument d'ailleurs je
sais des débats c'est des mots tout ça
tout à fait creux
je pense que nous avons besoin de
progrès nous avons besoin de plus de
pouvoir d'achat de plus de justice et
les plaies d'une meilleure santé et
d'une espérance de résidence
du coup on s'y retrouve et nous avons
besoin
d'europe et nous avons besoin d'une
europe forte ferme qui affiche sa
puissance et qui en même temps respecte
évidemment l'identité l'agression qui la
composent cible mais ça semble si vous
revenir sur le sujet j'aimerais poser
une autre question
les hollandais viennent d'intervenir
dans le capital d'air france j'ai du cru
que vous parliez des partisans de
françois hollande n'ont pas mal ils
interviennent dans le capital d'air
france nous on se retire la dp on se
retire la française des jeux
en gros ce type d' angie une liste
impressionnante d'entreprises
industrielles sont en difficulté
peut-être dont elle fermé beaucoup dans
les hauts de france mais aussi chez moi
où il ya peugeot scooters ou via une
autre entreprise qui peut disparaître
il y as concernant l'industrie une
désindustrialisation de plus en plus
important par minute qui se poursuit
c'est ce que j'ai dit en voyant le maire
la dernière fois la liste et les là
effectivement il ya plus de fermetures
de te que d'ouvertures de salies mais
depuis quelques mois seulement depuis la
fin 2010 rendez vous compte qu'avec ce
qui se passe avec l' usine ford plus
d'ouverture aux jours avec fermeture
oui mais ce qui se passe avec l' usine
ford ce qui se passe avec casque ovale
ce qu'il passe avec plusieurs
entreprises
on a là des savoir-faire des filières
technologiques qui vont disparaître et
un thuya beaucoup d'oeufs et d'eau alors
question heures la question est simple
est-ce que vous ne pensez pas comme l'a
fait obama lorsque tu general motors
était en difficulté qu'il ne faut pas
nationaliser temporairement une
entreprise pour lui permettre pour
garder les salariés des savoir faire
garder les machines garder les
investissements et ensuite lorsque
l'entreprise a repris
lorsqu'on a trouvé un repreneur le
l'étape se désengage juge alors
maintenant c'est un responsable je
prends l'exemple de peugeot oui
14 oui c'était un autre maintenant
peugeot va mieux l'état va se resserrer
notre temps c'était un autre temps non
non je suis pas du tout favorable à des
nationalisations de cette nature je le
savais je savais mais je dis à ces jeux
là je pense aux salariés je mesure tout
ça c'est des drames pour les uns et pour
les autres mais je ne peux pas vous dire
que je serais favorable à ça parce que
ça voudrait dire un état internet tout
le temps partout je le rappelle que
l'état n'a pas d'argent je rappelle que
l'état est en plein déficit
c'est ce que font les libyens voulaient
payer c'est ce que ford était malin on
ne sait pas ce que font les prix moi je
note qu'il ya beaucoup d'échecs
industriels et qu' il faut il ya
beaucoup d'échecs industriels et que ses
échecs industriels il quand même
commence à nous poser des questions
asko vallée alti force et un moment
donné ce qui s'est passé ce qui se passe
non le secrétaire d'état se cassait pas
sur cet exercice sur sable en sport est
tout à fait scandaleux
la positionnement l'attitude de ford est
absolument scandaleux
il a raison tout ministre demanderait
qu'on rende les 20 millions qui ont dû
être donnée à un moment donné pour
assurer le développement de l'entreprise
elle élit de lev ci forte veut partir
aux etats-unis allaient produire les
pièces
là bas il doit rembourser évidemment
tout ce qu'ils doivent rembourser on
verra si le ps veut dire comment comment
fonctionne le plan social bon je note
que alstom siemens
on est allé dans le mur c'est plus
industrie propre industrie s'était quand
même de façon différente mais par
exemple
la ministre veut supprimer l'impôt sur
la production par exemple
laissez nous laissions oui mais c'est
très nouveau parce que les républicains
dans présenté avec beaucoup
d'opiniâtreté
mais non mais écoutez c'est les débats
on part du débat à l'assemblée nationale
on parle pas d'un débat dans un bar de
vrais débats dans lesquels on propose
des choses dans lesquelles on les votes
on n'évoque pas nous avons proposé une
diminution des impôts surproduction et
des appeaux de production qui ont qui
rend la compétitivité de nos entreprises
de moins en moins fort par rapport à
tous les autres
regardez l'état de notre commerce
extérieur d'ailleurs donc nous avons
besoin
de réduire d'abord la fiscalité de
production des entreprises parce que les
entreprises c'est celle qui crée la
richesse quand j'ai dit ça j'ai pas le
prix nobel d'économie qui est encore
faut-il que ce soit l'onac ou miser sur
le coût du travail la taxe d'habitation
était une en a on a tout misé sur le
coût du travail
maintenant on est inférieure à
l'allemagne et s'il n'y aurait pas que
cela j'ai vu un grand journal qu'ils
assistent le problème de la
désindustrialisation n'était pas que
cela talent et on va chercher autre
chose
par exemple le fait que les entreprises
du cac40 investissent beaucoup plus
ailleurs qu'en france plutôt que
d'investir en france
je prends un exemple grande sujet des
grandes entreprises n'a plus que 12 % de
sa production en france et rigueur mais
tant mieux mais c'est exceptionnel pour
cent de la production a en france on
vendrait pas ailleurs c'est là
heureusement il existe heureusement je
suis pas défaitiste je pense que nous
devons être conquérant et que les
entreprises françaises que j'ai envie
moi les grandes entreprises françaises
au moins elles ont une vision
conquérante de l'espace mondial
on n'a pas à se retrouver notre coq
vis-à-vis du monde et si j'en ai repris
de la hauteur et on a une belle voiture
d'occasion attentes mais question finale
amélie de montchanin puisque le temps
alors sur les retraites font revenir à
un point vous avez longuement évoquée
moi je reste persuadé que la priorité
n'est pas l'âge la priorité c'est de
redonner une forme d'unité de justice
aujourd'hui moi je suis frappé par le
fait qu' une même personne évidemment
une même femme qu'elle soit
fonctionnaire qu'elles soient
travailleurs domicile quel choix
salariés qu'elle soit indépendante ou
qu'elle soit professions libérales pour
le même temps de travail pour les mêmes
cotisations à 62 63 64 ans quel que soit
l'âge que vous regardez elle n'a pas le
même droit leur retraite et que pour
notre priorité c'est des religions non
si vous êtes si vous
c'est les régimes spéciaux donc vous
êtes favorable à la suppression
immédiate des régimes spéciaux de la
sncf de la ratp et c'est en tout cas ce
que certains c'est oui oui oui nous
avons opté pour s'affirmer chez soi vu
autant de retraités pauvres arriver
maintenant la java c'est pour ça que le
si certains vont directement restos du
coeur non mais sont en difficulté en dix
ans la question terme et eric woerth
hermine j'ai vu qu'en allemagne se
discutait l'idée d'avoir un minimum
retraite à 900 euros ou sympa ne pas
accorder de pension et à bien des mamans
tête
cameron vous avez conclu avec le risque
que c'est pas une question d'âge c'est
parce que vous avez peur de ce débat
parce que c'est un débat qu'il est
difficile d'affronter c'est un débat
dans le kent et c'est un débat très
difficile d'affronter lés grands je
pense pas aujourd'hui on voit rien de
courageux dans ce que vous proposez
d'ailleurs on verra d'ailleurs j'en sais
rien à ce texte
on ne voit jamais mais en tout cas ça
fait toujours très peur il faut à un
moment donné dans l'intérêt général
parfois affronter aussi l'opinion
publique je crois que vous pouvez leur
porter témoignage au 30e oui ça m'a
l'air merci pour de bonnes raisons mais
aussi pour de ventes jamais fait aussi
allez merci seuil et dit merci beaucoup
à tous les deux d'être venu ce soir donc
interpellé
ils veulent qu'on l'a vu effectivement
dernière partie d'auditions publiques
avec nos deux journalistes des chaînes
parlementaires
avec nous on regarde mancini de public
sénat et ludovic faut de la chaîne
parlementaire assemblée nationale
bonsoir à tous les deux il ya une
question d'un internaute que je vous
volent être concerne l'algérie
l'internaute du figaro demander quelles
sont vos craintes
et quels sont vos espoirs si vous en
avez aujourd'hui vu la situation que je
vais réagir de façon dont très très
spontané c'est assez pathétique quand
même c'est assez pathétique parce que
c'est un grand pays est un grand pays
est un pays aussi extrêmement important
pour l'équilibré temps qui est encore un
équilibre dans ces régions là enfin
c'est assez pathétique de deux de ses
pattes et eames une démocratie c'est pas
ça parce que parce qu'un pouvoir c'est
passard plus on dépayse jeunes donc
comment peut-on comment peut-on alors
bien sûr qu'il faut faire très attention
de ne pas verser dans les
fondamentalismes envoyé à ce qu'ont
donné certaines évolutions mais mais
mais mais quand même enfin je pense que
les routes africa je prends souvent en
tout cas je vois passer la main monsieur
bouteflika
ce serment était un grand chef d'état un
moment donné mais enfin visiblement il
ne peut pas exercer ne peut pas exercer
donc c'est à dire que d'autres exercent
d'autres exercent
c'était des gens qui protège une
situation au travers de cela personne ne
sait qui d'ailleurs en tout cas sauf
probablement quelques grands
spécialistes
donc il ya des gens qui tirent les
ficelles d'une démocratie qui à ce
moment-là s'étouffer comment la jeunesse
de ce pays peut accepter ça c'est un peu
logique
eric woerth on est à moins de trois mois
des élections européennes qui auront
lieu en france le 26 mai et emmanuel
macron donne en quelque sorte cette
semaine le coup d'envoi de la campagne
européenne avec notamment une tribune
qui sera publié demain matin dans la
presse française et européenne avec eux
mais j'avais déjà lu d'après les
premières informations en tout cas
effectivement de rtl emmanuel macron
dans cette tribune plaide pour une
renaissance européenne avec concrètement
une remise à plat de l'espace schengen
il préférence européenne en matière de
marchés publics européens
un bouclier social pour lutter contre
les abus du travail détachées est ce que
ces propositions finalement vous
pourriez les signes et qu'est ce qui
vous différencie du président sur
l'origine des propositions qu'on a déjà
évoqué face et des propositions qui
traitent depuis très longtemps
tout ça s'il fait une tribune en tant
que pays pour dire ça c'est pas non plus
pas crier au génie
et puis sur les sur les mots j'en sais
rien je n'ai pas lu
j'aurai je réagi avec prudence à chaud
mais il est grand beau sur l'europe tout
le monde est capable d'en faire bon il
ya la question sur deux y vient d'être
justement on la construit ça veut dire
aussi comment on rend les opinions
publiques de plus en plus europhile
comment on fait pour cela quand on
conçoit en slovénie qu'on soit en france
ou qu'on soit en italie du sud comme on
essaye de faire en sorte pour créer un
état d'esprit européen
il s'a d'ebook pas beaucoup d'aidé des
dirigeants et probablement aussi des
milieux économiques et on doit pas
raconter d'histoires sur l'europe on
doit pas considérer que l'europe est un
bouc émissaire de tous ce qui ne marche
pas dans chaque pays parce que chacun
ses propres responsabilités si les
italiens ça ne marche pas ils ont leur
propre responsabilité si les français ça
marche pas c'est bien notre faute et
c'est pas la faute évidemment de l'ordre
ont accepté l'exposition concrètes non
c'est sans doute en raison notamment
lors la préférence européenne pour
apprendre public la préférence
européenne
on a 10 mai mais je sais tu es dans les
projets les règles quand on vous écoute
ayant pas que c'est toujours un décalque
abeilles il n'y a aucune idée nouvelle
c'est décidé moi je pense d'ailleurs que
parce que l'auto je pense d'ailleurs que
les idées nouvelles
en réalité on cherche toujours des idées
nouvelles meilleures la laine de la
vraie nouveauté ce serait d'appliquer et
d'appliquer un certain nombre d'idées
anciennes qui montrent qu'elle marche
ailleurs et que juste comme on n'a pas
le courage de le faire en france alors à
ce moment là on cherche des idées
nouvelles et en réalité c'est les mots
qui sont souvent nouveau mais pas les
idées et je pense que le pays
il est plutôt en train de reculer que
d'avancer et c'est bien ce qui
m'inquiète
et c'est bien ce qui m'inquiète et comme
responsable politique depuis maintenant
un certain nombre d'années c'est ce qui
me rend assez triste pour tous quand je
vois mon pays reculer plutôt qu avance
et je me dis en termes public
heureusement qu'il ya des entreprises
heureusement qu'il ya des gens qui en
veulent heureusement qu'il ya des
chercheurs qui cherchent des enseignants
qui en scène
enfin globalement notre pays il a plutôt
tendance à reculer et ça il faut arrêter
cela
et donc on a besoin de se réformer y'en
a pas rejoindre les rangs on n'a pas
besoin de grand débat on a besoin juste
l'enjeu est sincère crucial dans cette
période de l'avenir de l'union ça n'a
jamais été aussi crucial probablement et
depuis le début de l'union et nous
devons donc affiché à nos européanisme
fort clair précis et c'est cela que va
porter la liste des républicains et je
ne crois pas qu emmanuel macron il
déclenche le début de la campagne
c'est les républicains qui ont déclenché
le début de la campagne en lançant
d'abord les noms de leurs têtes de liste
en indiquant les certain nombre d'idées
en discutant conseil national de ce que
nous voulons faire
moi je crois que les républicains
doivent être aujourd'hui en situation de
gagner les élections européennes
nous devons gagner les élections
repéreront gala on doit se placer en est
à ce stade d'ambition et là on est
apparemment face à un duel entre fabien
macro et bien nous avons une liste nous
avons des leaders laurent wauquiez nous
vous nous verrons nous y contribueront
tous nous devons rompre ce débat qu
d'ailleurs voulu installer emmanuel
macron pendant longtemps avec le front
national où le rassemblement national
enfin ça ressemble un peu au front
national s'était même exactement la même
chose et les républicains dans une
période aussi troublé que celle où nous
vivons actuellement la france s'est
arrêtée ou elle ne réforment plus l idée
bas ou ne sais pas comment on va sortir
de ce débat où on ne sait pas si on sera
à 3-3 et demi pour cent de déficit
public d'ailleurs plus de dettes ça veut
dire moins de pouvoir d'achat
quand on ne sait plus tout ça on a
besoin à ce moment là d'avoir une
opposition qui soit une vraie alternance
crédible et les républicains doivent
représenter cela qu'il y ait quelqu'un
ils doivent gagner les élections et
doivent se cacher et sa démission
ça marchera ou pas j'en sais rien ça
dépendra de la qualité de notre campagne
du fait qu'on y va toucher mais surtout
est-ce que ce clivage dont vous parlez
cette opposition qu'installe emmanuel
macron face à marine le pen ils ne vous
prive pas de tout l'espace politique
non je crois pas du tout au contraire on
a un énorme espace politique
on n'a jamais eu autant d'espèces
politique depuis bien longtemps un
pouvoir quand même le moins qu'on puisse
dire
fragilisé extrêmement fragilisée attaque
et de ce qu'il est c'est à dire au fond
dans sa modernité dans sa capacité à
incarner la réforme de notre pays dans
la justice
donc il ya des réformes dit justice donc
ça peut pas fonctionner et de l'autre un
front national qui n'est juste la pâle
copie de tous les mouvements populistes
qu'on voit un peu partout pour une
droite qui va du centre droit jusqu'à
une droite plus conservatrices ou plus
traditionnelles cette droite là elle
doit avoir un message suffisamment fort
mais aussi suffisamment conques
conquérant pas uniquement bien sûr un
message de repli ou un message de d'une
europe qui défendra et qui protégerait
elle doit protéger l'europe ont fait de
la prose quand on parle c'est évident
mais au-delà de cela l'europe elle doit
montrer au monde qu'elle est présente et
bien présente sur ces valeurs comme
d'ailleurs sur son économie mais aussi
sur les valeurs qu'elle incarne
justement à propos vous disiez de parler
de repli vous aviez fait partie de ceux
qui ont exprimé des réserves au moment
de la désignation de françois xavier
bellamy comme tête de liste pour les
élections européennes sur la stratégie
de laurent wauquiez
vous disiez craindre un rétrécissement
sur finalement un parti de plus en plus
conservateur est ce que vous êtes
aujourd'hui rassurés valérie pécresse
qui avait elle aussi exprimé des
réserves a dit ce matin qu'elle
soutiendrait la liste des républicains
est ce que vous êtes engagés résolument
derrière votre tête de liste aux
européennes soient enfin ça va de soi
ces tracés leur histoire on a quand même
le droit à un parti politique de
dialogue parfois on n'est pas d'accord
ou alors faut faire autre chose alors il
vous faut des appuis ça va de soi non je
partage toujours mon opinion vous voyez
c est partager toujours votre opinion
laquelle partage depuis quelques jours
réserve mais pas contre monsieur bel ami
mais pour vous c'est extrêmement clair
voir je suis j'étais au rpr j'étais aux
républicains j'étais j'écris fin j'ai
créé j'ai fait partie de tous les gens
qui ont créé l'ump
donc je crois à ma formation politique
plus que jamais et je crois que les
républicains ils peuvent gagner les
élections européennes comme ils peuvent
représenter une force crédible
d'alternance représenter toute la droite
c'est uniquement cela ne ramènera normal
est-ce qu'ils soutiendraient évidemment
excusez-moi rigueur
vous dites que l ère doit être là la
force de la loi fer de lance de
l'européisme et spa met en scène un
niveau critique est un peu en creux une
des formes de re scepticisme chic
il est donné en soi que j'avais bel ami
je moi je n'ai rien dit tout ça je
parlais pas les deux partis
conservateurs génial on ne peut pas
résumer les républicains à une frange de
ceux de cette vaste
ce faire face est que nous représentons
donc ses facettes là elles doivent
briller de mille feux et briller de
mille feux
c'est assumer un certain nombre de
propositions nouvelles ou pas nouvelle
d'ailleurs mais elles doivent elles
doivent on doit attirer on doit donner
envie de voter pour nous à la fois sur
100 m à ses électeurs moi je ne suis pas
tête de liste je suis pas sur la liste
européenne
moi j'ai dre cette liste évidemment à
aller plus loin a exprimé de plus en
plus clairement cette idée que l'europe
s'est pas uniquement une protection
l'europe c'est le moyen d'aller plus
loin dans le monde de conquérir au fond
le monde par nos valeurs comme d'autres
l'ont fait sur le plan physique par
l'exploration par plein de choses et
qu'il n'y a pas de france en europe
ça n'existe plus tout ce qu'ils veulent
cela ils veulent la destruction de notre
pays de gaulle sera le premier a
toujours été le premier des européens et
de gaulle le serait encore plus
aujourd'hui donc nous devons puiser dans
notre histoire puiser dans notre
imagination dans nos efforts pour faire
gagner notre notre liste aux élections
européennes on va tous s'y consacrer et
en étant les plus europhiles de votre
famille politique
alain juppé on l'a vu la semaine
dernière avec un emmanuel macron jean
pierre raffarin semble plutôt pencher
pour un soutien à la république en
marche jean pierre raffarin d'ailleurs
laurent wauquiez lui demande de
clarifier sa position en vue des
élections européennes
c'est un coup dur c'est pourquoi vous
dites les plus europhiles valérie
pécresse est très europhile je suis leur
fils jean leonetti très europhile va ya
plein de gens qui sont très
leurs fines 7 on a deux anciens premiers
ministres on a deux anciens pros minutie
et urgent de chaunac a rappelé à l'ordre
il y en a un autre qui était votre
partie des relations très amicales avec
un juppé avec jean pierre raffarin mais
allez on va pas résumer les républicains
à cela d'avoir un gpu sortie du jeu
politique
aujourd'hui c'est une perte pour la
droite oui alain juppé d'un homme de
conviction et qui a beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup contribuer à réformer
notre pays avec beaucoup de moments
difficiles
bien évidemment doit jamais quelqu'un
partir comme cela je le regrette
évidemment à titre personnel mais il
faut regarder devant
jean pierre raffarin était aussi un
grand 1er mai ni jean pierre est
quelqu'un là il a reçu une lettre de
laurent wauquiez pour lui demander de
venir opposition politique et clarifier
sa position et est ce que vous pensez de
cette méthode je ne peux pas parler de
la méthode mais heureuse quand même sur
ce rappel à l'ordre est en effet pas
parler de la méthode sur le fond qu'elle
vous convient sur le thème sur le fond
laurent wauquiez a raison de demander à
jean pierre raffarin clarifier sa
position à deux mois d'une élection
majeure jean pierre raffin il est
républicain
donc moi j'appelle jean pierre raffarin
à soutenir la liste des républicains et
d'y apporter tout son european it est
basée à portée de ses idées oui je le
crois pourquoi pourquoi ce serait pas
possible il a plein d'amis jean pierre
raffarin il en démembrant lui-même je
vous donne une information et il va
publier une tribune dans le figaro de
demain jean pierre raffarin pourquoi je
soutiens le projet européen d' emmanuel
macron quelle est votre réaction
je ne connais pas cette tribune vous
demander de résumer wings excusez moi
j'ai pas tout le temps là ce médium et
hélas non son soutien au projet bien je
la mets m j'appelle jean pierre raffarin
a retiré cette tribune du figaro de
demain matin il est qu'ils adhèrent lui
au projet du président écoutez moi je
connais pas le projet du président et
jean pierre raffarin et connaît pas non
plus le projet des républicains parce
que ces projets ils sont pas sur la
table
donc il faut pas aller plus vite que la
musique s'il veut faire projet contre
projet qui regardent les deux types de
projets qui regardent ce qu'a dit
emmanuel macron sur l'europe qui est
assez éloigné de ce que disait
jean-pierre à un moment donné et ce que
nous dirons je l'espère dans cette liste
dans tout cas moi je serai celui qui
pousse qu'avec plaidé didier que celui
du chef de l'état et le projet européen
le plus abouti voilà ce que dit votre
ami jean-pierre
n'est pas aboutie ya pas de projet
européen depuis la sorbonne où est le
projet européen du président de la
république
où est il où est il il est il était en
se réconciliant tout d'un coup avec les
italiens en tapant sur en en écrasant
avant l'heure de son nom c'est beaucoup
d'efforts soutenir la liste des autres
partis conduite par ces jeunes mais là
jean pierre raffarin c'est un mauvais
coup pour votre parti mais je la fin
n'ont pas de mauvais coups c'est pas une
bonne nouvelle mais vous m'interrogez
sur une tribune que je n'ai pas lu qui
sera deux mains disponibles dans le
figaro excusez moi mais alors on n'est
plus dans la télé actualité on est dans
la tête ou quelques jours alain juppé
jean pierre raffarin ce n'est quand même
pas le symbole l'illustration quel bon
disait tu vas me faire dire cela je n'ai
pas envie de dire ça je ne crois pas
parce que vous pensez que dans ces
conditions les républicains doivent
regarder devant d'accord ils doivent pas
humilier ils doivent et humilier
personne ils doivent une mine et aucune
personnalité ça c'est extrêmement
important ce que et on doit réunir on
doit réunir ce que j'en regarde comme un
chef c'est vrai encore est la 201e
question qui reste posée est ce ici
j'aurais l'air à farah soutenait une
autre liste que celle de l air d facto
il serait plus dans l air ça c'est une
certitude et le sait d'ailleurs lui même
mais moi j'appelle jean pierre raffarin
à attendre avant de prendre sa décision
enfin c'est pas non plus un oracle on
n'est pas en train de se demander ce que
va faire
jean pierre raffin mais s'il veut
prendre position je le le minuit lui dis
amicalement en même temps jean pierre de
regarder et puis je sais pas ce que vous
avez remarqué mais toujours de très très
grande différence entre ce que dit le
président de la république est ce que
fait le président de la république donc
je la prendrai je lui me proposa d'être
très prudents alors son soutien voilà il
soutient il y avait du roi mercredi une
commission nationale d'investiture des
républicains justement concernant les
élections européennes est ce que pour
tourner la page des anciens premiers
ministres il faut donner une prime au
renouvellement pour les places en
particulier éligible dans la liste des
républicains on connaît le trio de tête
un certain nombre de
donnons deux députés européens sortants
reviennent rachida dati brice hortefeux
geoffroy didier et d'autres encore
est-ce qu'il faut une prime au
renouvellement notamment parmi les dix
quinze premiers qui ont de véritables
chances d'être élus n'ont ni plus ni
plus ni moins enfin je le renouvellement
c'est pas un truc qu'on ne remonte pas
sur son sur sa chaise en son temps car
comme un cabri en disant renouvellement
renouvellement mais la vie c'est plein
de gens d'expérience de deux des jeunes
comme des beaucoup moins jeunes et il
faut évidemment des personnes ou des
personnalités qui ont été député
européen on a dit ça sans arrêt sur les
mêmes plateaux mon dieu en france on
change change à l'arrêt les députés
européens se replacer un copain c'est
beau placer quelqu'un qui était battu il
y en a marre
regardez les allemands ils investissent
et compliqué le député européen d'avoir
un peu d'influencé compliqué d'être
président de commission européenne faut
des gens un peu
et dans ce cas là on prend des gens qui
ont de l'expérience et heureusement
qu'il ya des gens qui ont d'experts je
note que dans est ce que je sais les
trois premiers il y en a deux qui n'ont
pas été député européen le troisième l'a
été il faut que derrière évidemment
faire ce que vous avez dit il ya
quelques secondes il faut veiller à ne
pas humilier des personnalités c'est les
personnes habituellement par ludovic
nadine morano rachida dati
il faut leur faire une place non mais
moi je vais parler de jean pierre
raffarin je parlais d'alain juppé je
parlais de cette personnalité parfois y
ait eu des mots très durs à leur
rencontre et je ne partage pas ses mots
pour tout vous dire
enfin la vie politique et les brutales
elle est ce qu'elle est il faut aussi
dire les choses qu'il faut lire les
intérêts mais mais je pense que les
personnes que vous avez cités elles
n'ont pas démérité dans
l'accomplissement de leur mandat et que
nous avons besoin mais nous avons besoin
d'eux dans le rock la chevronnée
chevronnés si vous mettez que des gens
nouveaux
si vous mettez que des jeunes
journalistes pour faire un journal cela
sera un formidable ce sera fait ce jeu
sera joyeuse ce sera aux aguets mais ça
me manquera peut-être d'un petit peu
quelque chose dans la vie c'est le
mélange la vie c'est le mélange c'est
évidemment de brasser des générations et
nous devons le faire dans satif on a
appris il ya quelques minutes que la
droite européenne a officiellement lancé
la procédure d'exclusion du ppe de
viktor orban et de son parti la décision
sera rendue le 20 mars le ppe c'est là
où siègeraient
lesquin au parlement européen est ce que
cette procédure d'exclusion c'est une
bonne chose
je n'ai pas vu ça c'est quoi la droite
européenne
ces douze cpe 12 parties appartenant
péter mais ce n'est pas tout le ppe non
non c'est pas tout le ppe donc en jaune
il ya des jeux aussi de d'état deux
nations il ya des points je crois que il
ya des déchets il ya des points comptés
évoqué enfin monsieur sorbonne n'est pas
blanc bleu évidemment je pense à liberté
de la presse des points comme ça qu'ils
ont été signifiées et qui montre que
c'est une démocratie probablement plus
compliquée encore que là que l'un
hautement face est une personnalité qui
est occupé depuis très longtemps
donc honnêtement je n'en sais rien je
connais très peu son pays et je connais
très peu monsieur or bad
je pense que ce faux pas en faire
l'alpha et l'oméga de la de la campagne
tout ce que je sais c'est que on peut
pas faire une campagne uniquement en
disant il ya les bons européens les
mauvais parce que si vous faites ça si
vous faites ça vous fait du clivage et
je crois pas que et d'ailleurs c'est
vrai sur le plan national aussi on peut
pas réunir les français en clivant les
français et on peut pas réunir les
européens en clivant les européens
soient pas être naïf veut pas dire qu'il
faut pas réagir se veut pas dire qu'il
faut pas dire non quand il faut dire non
mais il faut faire attention au débat un
peu trop simpliste on se sent très
prudent est ce que c'est parce que
finalement une éventuelle explosion du
parti populaire européen ce serait un
cadeau fait aux assemblement nationale
aux parties les plus populistes et puis
également à la république en marche et à
ses alliés éventuels en revenant à ce
qu'il va j'entends parler tout à l'heure
entre nationalistes et progressistes des
macros cherche visiblement à recréer une
sorte d'alliance on ne sait pas très
bien avec qui d'ailleurs est comment
mais le fait depuis deux ans parce que
s'il souhaite être au fond celui qui
sait pas si la présidence de la france
lui suffit peut-être faut-il d'une
présidence européenne
donc il élargit son champ d'intervention
moi je crois que le ppe etc existent
depuis bien longtemps c'est totalement
inconnu de la part des français
probablement d'une part bonne partie no
dieter mais c'est un regroupement des
droits de toutes natures avec une
histoire avec l'histoire des pays sont
extrêmement différentes aussi les uns
des autres
enfin ça a toujours tenu ça a toujours
tenu et ça a toujours permis de faire
avancer l'europe
on doit continuer à faire avancer
l'europe y a jamais eu autant de nuages
qui s'amoncellent au dessus dans ce jeu
met donc est il faut être clair d'où
l'importance du scrutin ce scrutin il
est fondamental pour la france mais il
est fondamental pour l'europe
merci beaucoup eric woerth d'avoir été
avec nous aujourd'hui merci à tous les
deux bonsoir à tous on se retrouve bien
sûr la semaine prochaine bonsoir
[Musique]